that's one of the worst need to deliver
is horrifying
that's Ronda Rousey was so good at that
she would tie girls up in that judo
clinch and then just knee the [ __ ] out
of their body was ruthless because she
was so good at like upper body control
she could tie you up so well from judo
Hogan he caught me with the right hand
of the body she would just get a hold of
girls and then she started [ __ ]
nuking him with knees to the body she
did that Sara McMann god damn this is
good yeah this is really so tense right
like anything can happen here fortunes
can change the drop of a hat
whoo Canelo is firing him huh Oh 4449
244 of power punches god damn it that is
so insane favor of golovkin his Ronda
coming back you think I don't think
she's gonna wrestling I think it's over
yeah I think so I don't think she wants
to do it anymore you know for whatever
reason you could break that down
psychologically all day you know Matt
Sarah had a great line that I never
forgot he said a long time ago that
everybody likes to be the hammer oh yeah
but nobody wants to be the nail yeah
there's always if you're the nail can
you come back yeah and there's always
gonna be finders out there that you
can't take down and you're gonna be
forced to stand sure and the level of
striking right now with the girls is at
an all-time high and if you ain't top on
top of your striking even if you get
really good it's still Russian roulette
these girls are some of the like
Shevchenko and Amanda Nunez yes you know
so Dane you can't take the person down
you have to strike and then it becomes a
kickboxing battle how good is your
kickboxing boxing batter where you hope
and pray that something goes wrong and
you get it to the ground
hey you know what Rhonda has good
striking it's not terrible but even if
it was great there's a lot of great
strikers out there so at the end of the
day you're gonna be forced to win a
kickboxing tournament at the very top
it's gonna be very hard she didn't
wrestle her whole life she's doing judo
at
Olympic level yeah she has great
takedowns she was able to ragdoll most
of her opponents but right now man it's
gonna be very hard for her to take these
girls down right now she's gonna be
forced to strike so then it becomes you
know she could win some she could lose
some how many people did she beat that
or strikers as good as Holly Holm Amanda
Nunez none none of them were as good as
her the only one who was closest cat
Zingano and she caught cat real early
earlier at the first round right yeah
with an armbar cat just charged at her
and got caught with an armbar yeah I
think Rhonda said I think she can't
deserve better like she she knew that
that was just a kind of a fluke you know
what Kat said that the reason why she
charged out of like that is cuz like she
took a furious beating in that Amanda
Nunez fight she won the fight but she
got [ __ ] up in that first round like
real bad and she's like I didn't want to
go through that again
but she was I just want to charge at her
and get ahold of her I'm such an if
Ronda Rousey decided to on the girl she
couldn't throw or takedown plan B is
that flying guard pool she had the guard
for it she has an amazing guard mazing
arm bar from the guard her plan should
have been in my opinion to get the fight
to the ground try to be on top try to
use your judo if that didn't work we
have to go to pool and guard the rocket
with someone like Amanda Nunez is that's
not going to happen
anybody think you're gonna get eaten up
with punches when you try to get close
Amanda's got something yeah you got his
arms in order to pull guard you got you
got to pull off a legit shot to get that
to react to get them to sprawl and
that's when you pull guard when you're
under him and they sprawl you time it
perfect it's it's a technique it's just
like a takedown
regards amazing just like in that fight
with that surge Omar I he was on his
back hurt and and his opponent wouldn't
get on top of this let's pay attention
to this because some [ __ ] has happening
here
[Applause]
[Music]